dos oficiales de la policía del
Capitolio junto con once miembros
demócratas de la cámara de
representantes buscan responsabilizar a
Trump por las lesiones físicas y
psicológicas que sufrieron Durante los
disturbios del seis de enero del 2021
cuando simpatizantes de Donald Trump Se
tomaron el Capitolio la demanda fue
presentada en virtud del estatuto
redactado después de la guerra civil
estadounidense respuesta al club klux
Klan que permite indemnizaciones por
daños o perjuicios cuando se utiliza la
fuerza las amenazas o la intimidación
para impedir que los funcionarios del
gobierno lleven a cabo sus funciones en
respuesta Trump argumentado que está
protegido de esta demanda por la
inmunidad absoluta conferida a un
presidente que desempeña sus funciones
oficiales sin embargo departamento de
Justicia instó al tribunal de
apelaciones a rechazar las afirmaciones
generales de inmunidad presidencial
presentadas por el expresidente Trump en
el litigio civil en torno a la
insurrección del seis de enero del 2021
cabe Resaltar que esta es la primera vez
que el departamento de Justicia se
refiere directamente a la cuestión de
inmunidad civil de Trump por su conducta
relacionada al 6 de enero